okay good afternoon and welcome to the
meeting the baby district council's
cabinet i'm councillor clive arthy
deputy leader of the council and i will
be chairing the meeting
firstly some domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
and finally we will be using e-voting
for the meeting on the modern.gov app so
please good members make sure they are
logged in and ready to use it
i'd like to remind everybody present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have considered
consented rather to being filmed
by entering the meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded by
the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film or photograph
or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i thought it would be helpful to clarify
for councillors present today and any
members of the public that are watching
that due to illness
our leader councillor john ward
is not able to attend the meeting in
person today
however thanks to our hybrid meeting
technology
he has been able to join us online to
introduce a number of reports on the
agenda and to answer any questions
council award will not be able to fully
participate in the meeting
as his virtual attendance doesn't comply
with the requirement for councillors who
are voting
to be physically present in the meeting
room
accordingly council award cannot chair
this meeting as is usually the case he
cannot propose or second a motion and
he's not able to participate in the
debate
also he cannot vote on any item
this could go wrong of course but we did
run a test earlier and
it worked
so if i can move to the agenda please
item one
is apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councillor melvisi
councillor gould and of course council
ward
okay
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary other registerable or
non-registerable interests from members
anybody
councillor busby yeah i think i probably
ought to in relation to hamilton road
and its potential work with weber growth
as chair of waver growth
okay thank you
but you have received dispensation is
that correct i have received a
dispensation
just to be clear you're chairman of baby
growth
okay
any others members
no
item three to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received chair
item four questions by councillors can't
receive chair my channel
thank you all it was um
since uh leaving the cabinet and
becoming a normal member of the council
um it's come across my mind it would be
very wise or very uh appropriate if all
members could be sent a calendar invite
for cabinet meetings i think it's
something we ought to do um to put them
in their diary so that all members are
aware when they are and can book them in
their calendar early enough so there's
not any conflict i think it's something
quite simple and i think it will be
beneficial to all members
okay thanks for that is of course in the
timetable of meetings
yeah
and we can do that too
okay
move on to did we do item four questions
by councillors i think we did
none receive chair item five matters
referred by the overview and scrutiny or
joint audit and standards committees
referred to okay
item six is a standing item forthcoming
decisions list but of course we had a
meeting on tuesday and nothing has
changed
so move to item seven
and
this is bca
2213 quarter four performance
and we have the cabinet member for
customers digital transformation and
improvement to introduce the report
council allison mccraw
thank you chair i'm very pleased to
introduce this quarterly report this is
for
quarter 4 of 2021-2022
splitting to its usual
separate areas um rather than go through
in detail um everything in that report
it's a lengthy one i have got some
highlighted notes from the main
directorates if you'd like me to go
through some of those notes
but if you prefer me to just refer to
them if any people have any questions
i'm happy to do that as well okay i'll
take direction from you as chair
well i'm happy
i'll carry on i'm happy well did you say
that you wanted to take questions i can
take questions or i can just provide the
notes i have in front of me but i think
the report speaks for itself i should
add by the way that this uh format will
be changing at some time in the next
three quarters had been hoped it would
be by quarter two at the moment it looks
like it's more likely to be quarter
three before we see the new format the
information contained of course will be
the same
uh so anyway if there's any questions
either i can take them myself
or they could be taken by the respective
cabinet member for that portfolio
okay did you say you wanted to present
some notes as well no i can't i'm just
saying if you wish me too
i think so yes that's fine okay so let's
just take the various sections starting
off with the economy um cycle parking
for shortly has been secured and
improved cycle facilities near cop dock
park and ride
the lc whip the local cycling and
walking infrastructure plan development
work has been completed a draft
sustainable travel
vision has been endorsed by cabinet and
this has been forwarded to suffolk who
will be largely responsible for
implementation
we've developed a marketing campaign
promoting attractions and holidays in
weber through visit suffolk
in the environment portfolio 56 solar
panels at the wenan depot are now
connected to the grid and they are
generating electricity
the main construction work on the solar
carports at the kingfisher in sudbury
was completed and the project completion
was scheduled for quarter one of 2022
2023 and i believe that is actually been
completed
so the lot of this report of course is
looking forward from quarter four into
what is now the present there was a
problem with these reports
uh working with the suffolk waste
partnership developing a work plan and
we started an educational and
promotional campaign to reduce our
contamination rates in our recycling and
to increase our glass recycling
performance
in the customers
sphere we've implemented our automated
telephone service for council tax and
business rates over the annual billing
period as a trial with 123 customers
using this option
we commenced the initial demos for our
digital platform to replace our website
our online forms and to improve our
digital customer experience and you'll
be hearing more about that in the
forthcoming months
although unfortunately call waiting
times increased to 3 minutes and 55
seconds compared to an annual average of
about 3 minutes and 16 seconds we saw a
higher call volume from council tax
calls which always come in quarter four
and in this year in this quarter this
year uh council tax inquiries were
considerably increased by the
uncertainty about 150 pounds coming from
central government and being repaid to
people through their council tax bills
that caused some confusion and led to
longer call waiting times
and also there were calls concerning
storm eustis if you remember a time when
we had storms
in communities uh officers have started
booster had started planning for the
national armed forces day for hadley in
23rd of june that went very well
upgrading the cctv system and transfer
of monitoring and maintenance to west
suffolk council is now complete eight
cameras are installed and operational in
hadley and 15 in sudbury
and in baber uh 270 000 pounds of
funding have now been spent to support
local community projects
in well-being free activities were
available in weber during february half
term for children in receipt of free
school meals
38 children attended hadley pool and
leisure center and 43 attended
kingfisher leisure centre for swimming
sessions with 49 children also attending
adventure days and the family park
cooking
we've worked with everyone active to
develop health pathways offering those
referred by the gps and discharged from
hospital with long-term conditions a
package of rehab rehabilitation at abby
croft leisure center
in housing uh there was a handover of
nine council homes for social rent in
branson i have to say i'm very pleased
about that
we started the tenants engagement
strategy and improved our choice-based
lettings processes to speed up new
tenants getting housed
that's the basic highlights but i'm
happy to take or direct any questions to
the cabinet members
that's fantastic thank you very much
as i did on tuesday i'm going to invite
questions from other councillors present
before i come on to cabinet questions
and debate
other councillors present any questions
yes councillor hot
yeah just uh something councilman crawl
said about the solo carports in sudbury
they're not complete
um just to update them on that um they
are still cordoned off and are not
operational
um i'm aware from fiona there is
supply issues for components needed to
complete the project but i would urge
the council to consider opening up the
carport bays so that the car park is
fully usable and operational
um as soon as possible because there is
no i don't believe there's a time frame
on delivery of those components so i
think for the benefit of all that would
be better for the people of sudbury and
i'm sure cats around would second them
okay do you want an update answer on
that question
i'll direct that to office fiona please
um
yes we this is not our direct contractor
this is actually a supply chain issue
and it's an it's an international global
issue in terms of these inverters that
are required um we have been
um pushing the contractor but to be
honest there's not very much
contractually that
we can do because it's a supply chain
issue further down down the lane um we
absolutely acknowledge we need to try
and reopen the car parks we're just
trying to make sure that um
that the
solar car ports in their existing
condition are safe uh so that we can
open spaces as soon as possible and
we'll be um getting some communications
out around that in the next few days
thanks for that and thank you council
hall for the question i think this is
this
everybody in electricity across the
world elon musk has been complaining
about any other questions
i will come to you next i'm sure
um non-cabinet members any other
questions no
councillor osborne
thank you vision to myself sitting there
for the moment um
yeah thanks for the report um
um customers page 16
um
there's an increase in the percentage of
abandoned calls
um
which was 22 that's an 8 increase from
quarter 3 now
it could be that this first quarter when
we get the report it will show an
improvement but what are we doing to
actually address the number of abandoned
calls
so when it comes to the call center at
the moment and particularly in this last
quarter quarter four
whenever you've got an increased waiting
time it follows that you're also going
to have
a slight a longer chance of people
abandoning simply because they're
waiting longer
now when you're dealing with the council
tax which was the principal part of
these queries and people were asking
questions about the repayment and how
they were going to get theirs
the first people to be repaid were those
who were paying by established direct
debits historical direct debits that are
around for some time those people who
had just taken out direct debits would
have to wait until all the others were
paid so there were some uncertainties in
the final analysis anybody who was not
had didn't have a direct debit uh set up
will find themselves uh being refunded
but it took a long time to explain that
i would say that i think when it comes
to people abandoning calls don't forget
that this doesn't mean they can't call
back later when call volumes are lower
and
with that is usually our experience i'm
also taking note that the satisfaction
level um amongst our customers is quite
high still at four stars
yeah did you want to come back yeah
thank you mr chairman um yeah i i
understand and i appreciate the fact
that you'll always have an upturn when
you've got the council tax billing
time period and also with the added to
that 150 pounds rebate i understand that
but we know when these things are coming
forward at least we have
months notice of it if not longer do we
put additional resources into that when
we know there's going to be a surge of
cause
yes we do as far as we possibly can
because we're always but there is
actually an overall um
overarching difficulty in recruitment
across the entire council that's
affecting quite a number of things that
we would like to see
done even more easily and also training
uh people on customer service on the
phones it's not the easiest job in the
world it takes a couple of months or so
to settle in feel comfortable with the
role i've done it myself um
so yeah it's not great we are still
recruiting and we are still training
people and we do
shift resources around where those
resources are available i don't know if
sarah has anything to add to that
increases as well
and i've heard
sort of comparisons with utility
companies and you know
people who say well this isn't as bad as
that but that's not really who we ought
to be judging ourselves against um you
know i would like to see
our answer times down to below a minute
myself
um
it's one minute 45 and that's a very
very stiff target by any standards okay
sarah did you want to come in
thank you councillors um yeah just to re
really reiterate some of the comments
that council macro has has already
mentioned
we do absolutely have an aspiration to
improve those waiting times i wouldn't
want anybody to think that we were
complacent about those but the reality
is is that since the pandemic we've seen
a significant upturn in the volume of
calls
and averaging
on the statistics there you can see
they're averaging up to nearly 600 which
you know is 50
if not more increase on what we've
previously had and just to say that
actually even in this quarter and i'm
sure you'll see that in the performance
when we present quarter one
those those call numbers are still
increasing as a consequence of
complexity from people with housing
issues with revenues and benefits
inquiries particularly relating to the
energy rebate
um we are doing as much as we possibly
can to
obviously we offering our staff over
time so that we can call customers back
outside of our our normal working hours
we are permanently recruiting we've had
an effort out for the best part of
probably five months
to to gain additional staff but it is a
very competitive market out there at the
moment
and we do work with services across the
organization to encourage them to to let
us have their staff in order to field
inquiries at really busy times but we
have to be realistic about the fact that
if we ask staff for example from the
revenue service that's actually less
staff for them to process those energy
rebate payments to get them out so we're
in a little bit of a catch-22 but we are
doing everything that we possibly can
including for example improving our
chatbot functionality to make sure that
customers can self-serve as much as
possible on the website so that they
don't have to to call us but we are
actively trying to improve those wait
times particularly with recruitment of
additional staff into that space
counseling program do you want to
comment tonight i have to presume that
you might want to come
comment on the the increased web
activity um the increased chatbot
activity
so there's
the increase online um which presumably
is is taking some of the pressure off
you'd think so wouldn't you but of
course the different different
difficulty is is that despite the
increase of say 173 percent from quarter
three and chatbot activity 81 in
automated telephony um and the increase
as you say in the web visits effectively
uh it's growing in all quarters and thus
so despite that having a vast increase
in uptake on those areas we still have
um you know problems in the call
answering
so
it hasn't taken all the pressure off
we've got to increase the chatbot the
whole point about the chatbot system is
it's being rolled out progressively
and a larger number of areas that we
deal with and that matter will allow us
then to take some more of the pressure
off
but it's an ongoing process
okay
any other questions councillor busby
along those lines do we have uh
a response when people ring in say
i mean if we've just sent out our
council tax letters
would there be a response which says if
you're ringing about your council tax
please
refer to the website or whatever to stop
the call having to go through the same
with the
150 quid rebate on the on the council
tax seems like you could cut a lot of
the calls out at source before they come
through
i'll just leave that one in the air um
economy
i did warn you
look there's been a fantastic amount of
stuff done work done and it looks very
good i'm just concerned that they don't
all the efforts aren't aligning with the
objectives
if you take objective one it says
and be a test bed for new innovation in
clean growth industries
i don't recall seeing any of that
objective two will be becoming a growing
area for innovation enterprise and
creativity
and objective three
we will raise levels of aspiration and
ambition
i'm not convinced that all the things
that we're doing
okay are delivering to those three
objectives i mean they're great
objectives very tough objectives and the
kind of objectives that we ought to be
aiming for
but i'm not sure that the right hand is
delivering what the left hand wants
so what are you saying you saying that
the the
section on um progress and the section
on what we plan to do next you saying
that they don't marry up with the
objective
basically yeah we're doing a lot of work
on economy but it's not delivering to us
achieving the objectives that we've set
right
so you're saying that there's not as
much in progress as they should be
there's plenty in progress right but not
towards the objectives it's not whatever
we're doing in here
isn't going to deliver the objectives
that we've set ourselves
like
being a test bed for
new innovation in clean growth
industries
can somebody tell me where
what have we done to help deliver that
okay i'm not sure if it's yeah it's not
quite a question perhaps not fully but
anyway we'll get
we'll get fiona to attempt to help with
an answer
um
well i can answer um
which is fortunate um so i would i was
not wanting to to disagree with one of
our councillors but they do absolutely
uh follow the broad
headings that we have there um the three
headings that we have are taken from our
economic recovery plan and they are a
broad
set of
themes across that recovery plan
as we report month on month not every
single
item that sits
within connected and sustainable for
example in any given month is going to
do all of that but if you look
collectively across the year then all of
our projects relate directly to those
three themes so if i pick up um
i think one of your points was around um
the test bed um the uh knowledge
transfer partnership that we're working
on with the university of essex for
example which university of essex have
put a large amount of money into that
will be launching shortly across weber
and that's absolutely about
working with small businesses to create
test beds
and support them to grow to be
fast-tracked innovative innovative
businesses that will deliver large
amounts of economic growth for the
district so that's one example
i'm happy to take it offline and have
many more discussions about many of the
other examples
okay just before you do in the first
test of our new technology
i think we've got john ward who would
like to provide an answer to the
question as well
this is the first test of the new
technology
yeah thanks chairman uh i must admit i
was surprised by the uh the question and
fiona has covered a number of the things
that uh i was going to say uh to be
honest but um i i think that um as fiona
said these other themes in the economic
recovery plan um and uh the items that
are listed here plus lots of others are
are addressing these themes um
fiona's mentioned the the university of
essex knowledge transfer program but
also things like innovate local um the
the opening of the new innovation lab in
sudbury all of these um components
that uh when put together will
will deliver against um these each of
these objectives um so
that there is a huge amount going on
um and um
and not all of it done by just just
labor acting alone but also working in
partnership with with others in in the
county as well so um
i i i'm very confident that we are
delivering against these objectives
um and we'll continue to do so and and
that we are showing um measurable
achievements against those
thank you
councilman council mccraw
i've just wondered if the outcomes
focused reporting that we expect to be
using in the future might make things a
little clearer for councillor busby i
think that might be fair to say because
that's the very purpose of having
outcomes focuses
okay yes i'm sure it will
look
picky about it but
in the first one objective one solar car
park carports project in sudbury on
track for delivery what the hell's that
got to do with it being a test bed for
new innovation in
growth industries or being one of the
best connected places in suffolk
doesn't that doesn't mean anything
successful 90 000 grand confirmed for
changing places bid for baber for
leveling up that's not to do with
new innovation in clean growth planning
application for the park entrance that's
nothing to do with new innovation in
clean growth
good levels of it you know it's
the stuff there is good but it doesn't
lead to achieving the objective
but that's just to be fair i think the
objective is connected and sustainable
clean electricity how can that not be a
clean growth industry and you and a new
innovation in putting in
so recharging on a solar carpal that
seems to me to fit the definition almost
perfectly
it's not an industry that we have
developed
we're expected to develop the industries
but certainly to use them in advance and
in their use
okay so
you're asking if we are even innovators
in that sense in usage we are i think
um
we'll move on there councillor buzzby
you can have a little think though and
ask another question in a minute if you
want i'm going to take council mclaren
next
thank you chair
um my question is about the reality of
the cost of living crisis
um
obviously we're wanting to increase
digital competence amongst our residents
has there been any recognition
that
with the cost of living crisis we could
see
a reduction in the ability of families
and individuals
to use
online devices
something like uh
wi-fi
it could be quite expensive
for families
what are we
are we sort of
considering that
thank you
i think the question was that with the
cost of living crisis are we expecting
that there might actually be less on
online activity
okay
council macro
i can't honestly say that uh that is
included necessarily in the um cost of
living response that's been prepared
um a lot of things have been considered
i mean effectively what we're talking
about is a general shortage of money and
the suggestion might be that one of the
things to go might be people
reducing their
spending on digital connection now a
number of the major isps have been
contacted by central government and i
think the major isps have all agreed
that they will provide reduced packages
for those members of the public most in
need
beyond
their doing that we would then have what
we've already stated as the option of
our discretionary payments to certain
circumstances but i'm not sure that that
would be one of those circumstances but
then they are discretionary payments i
think it's very much a matter we take
each case on its own merits aware of the
overall situation
um i'm not going to try and prioritize
which is the most important compared
food compared to digital um um
ability access okay that's just i don't
think it's something we've included
specifically are there any other
questions i remind you this is just for
noting so there's no debate on it
councillor busby
thank you
uh customers
the complaints that we've received the
200 odd
complaints have they been analyzed in
into categories and
does that go to ons for
interrogation
off the cuff um i will pass you back to
sarah but i do know that a great number
of these complaints made are in fact
turn out not to be complaints the first
thing you need to do is analyze those
which actually can be solved very simply
one one question one answer so very
often most of them tend to revolve
around a missed bin which we have a
system to get picked up within usually
the day or so usually sometimes the same
day sometimes the next day so when
they're complaints they're very low
level complaints what we are analyzing
is the ones we raised to a higher level
and those seem to be falling but i will
pass you on for more detail over to
sarah wilcock
thank you councillor busby we we do
indeed record all the complaints that
come in and we can provide the detailed
breakdown by quarter of
the volumes
per service areas
they do reach a wide variety and
sometimes are related to
services in terms of volumes of
outstanding work in those areas
naturally we have a percentage of missed
beans that will will
will be
part of those numbers but also things
like housing repairs for example where
we know that we've got some work to do
to to get up to speed we'll account for
some of that as well i'm happy to
provide some further information to to
yourself and cabinet on on the breakdown
of that and we have in the past indeed
uh taken more detailed information to uh
overview and scrutiny
okay thanks i think probably the best
place for it
yeah i've got a couple of things then on
uh i guess coming across communities and
well-being
one of the key issues that are affecting
communities at the moment uh are redoing
their neighborhood plans because of the
jlp
being
not thrown out but being postponed
and i know at least two of mine are now
altering their neighborhood plans to
exclude
sites i'm not convinced this is the
right approach
are the communities going to have
an opportunity to contribute
to the part two of the jlp
before
the inspector signs it off
yes
okay
any other questions
no
councillor owen i did say earlier on
that i was going to take questions from
other members followed by but i'll make
an exception if you want just
if you've got a question this is not for
debate it's just for noting so i'm happy
to take your question yeah no it's okay
it's it's only the back on what mary was
saying on sort of the cost of living and
everything with the advice center only
open
twice
a week maybe we could extend that to
three times a week so maybe if they
can't afford their internet maybe they
can come down to the town that's all
okay thanks we do actually have a loan
system for
ipads and they can be loaned and they
are wi-fi available by dongle
which is already paid for so in that
instance you could say that that
provision is being made
um we always monitor the usage of the
the
access point
advice center access points through
sudbury libraries and
so far
usage seems to match the
required need
in terms of the number of calls handled
in the months
the officers are neither being
overstretched or left um idle
okay thanks we've picked out a few
things that we've had issues with but i
think generally there's a lot of good
news in here
there is one little bit that i picked
out which was actually an answer to a
question from tuesday's meeting about
garden waste
subscribers
um and um there's further
good news i think if you attended the
briefing with regard to the tree canopy
survey um which is going to be um
available soon
so this is just for noting if there are
no other no other questions
there is one other question councillor
osborne well it's not actually a
question i'm saving it for debate but if
we're not going into debate
i'd just like to point out on page 29
under housing
the disabled facilities grant if members
will recall about two years ago 18
months ago we were struggling to spend
60 percent of that grant
there's been a lot of promotional work
done on it and i'm now pleased to report
that actually a hundred and four percent
of that grant has been spent or is
committed that's a fantastic result
that's gone from as i say sixty 60 right
up to over 104 over 100 so
that's fantastic news and on the fly
tipping you know i'm always
like an old record i suppose raising my
concerns about domestic flight of him so
because of my concerns i had a meeting
with public realm to discuss how we can
reduce the level of domestic fly tipping
on our developments and some really good
actions have come out of that i'm not at
liberty to say what they are here today
because i need to get approval to those
actions but i will let all members know
what those actions are going to be once
they've been approved but it was a good
meeting and there was some really good
results coming out of it so hopefully
we'll be starting to address that level
okay thanks for that
councillors i think
you've had all of the questions that you
wanted it is just for noting can we note
the report and move on
thank you
and move on to item eight
which is
bca22 stroke 13 the uk shared prosperity
fund
we've got two cabinet members involved
here
councillor mary mclaren and um
councillor john ward council mclaren did
you want to go first with an instruction
or have you arranged something with
council members
i've arranged with john that i will go
second okay right can we bring
council john ward
live online thank you
already
we're ready
right good technology is working german
have faith
right
i would like to introduce paper bca2213
to update cabinet on the development of
the council's draft uk shared prosperity
fund investment plan and the associated
public engagement activities
the shared prosperity fund was launched
by the government in april 2022 to
replace eu structural funds as part of
the wider leveling up agenda
there are two parts to the fund
multiplier which addresses the need to
improve adult numeracy skills and the
district shared prosperity fund which
aims to support district and borough
councils build upon their own strengths
and address local needs while creating
pride and place and also which will
develop a sorry which will deliver
against the missions identified in the
leveling up white paper
in consultation with the key
stakeholders and partners identified in
section six we are currently developing
an investment plan for baber midsuffer
addressing how the three shared
prosperity fund prior priorities of
community in place
supporting local business and people and
skills can support our vision for the
districts and our
economy communities and well-being
strategic priorities
several projects have been identified
from the communities and wellbeing
strategies and the economic recovery
plan and these have been grouped into
six project themes
community engagement and development
town centre and cultural programmes
events and festivals
recruitment support business support
including net zeros activities and
finally skills and employability support
baba has been allocated just over a
million pounds over the next three years
and the financial details including how
the total will be split are provided in
section 8.
some of the funds will be top slice to
support delivery of suffolk wide
priorities for shared areas of delivery
such as skills and business support
the investment plan must be submitted to
government by monday first of august and
so we cannot delay finalization of the
plan
now i'd like to hand over to council
mclaren who wishes to say a few words as
many of the interventions fall within
her portfolio and also for her to
propose the recommendations thanks
chairman
thank you council warden you will be
available to answer questions answer
questions if required
thank you council mclaren thank you
chair
thank you john
communities have been working very hard
in a very short time scale
to
consult wild widely
regarding what they propose
as
possible projects for this fund
i i was quite surprised
the communities team had
actually consulted 18 different
organizations to come up with their
proposals
so given the relatively low level of
funding to be allocated and the time
scales
communities have developed developed
investment priorities which are based on
existing priorities in the communities
and well-being delivery plans
they are
youth social prescribing project
the youth social prescribing project
will help young people to make
connections with their communities
improve their well-being to build
positive and reliable relationships and
to learn career and life skills for
achieving their goals
this project will predominantly target
young people at secondary schools aged
11
to the sixth form enabling them to
access the support and activities they
need when and where they need the most
rural youth development scheme
this is to develop a programme that
works alongside rural communities
offering targeted practical support to
develop sustainable youth work provision
within their local neighborhood and
identifying need and activity
and this is important
in collaboration with young people
community digital infrastructure
projects a digital a digital project
which will enable communities to
self-serve
share and have access to local
information
the detail of this project will be
worked up over the c on
the oncoming months
development of a community supermarket
a community supermarket shares the food
bank aim of helping people on low
incomes however it does not supply
emergency food parcels and occasional
sport but longer term help
this model will primarily support those
individuals and families who fluctuate
above and below the line of financial
security
providing a consistent point of support
to avoid them falling into financial
crisis
and lastly
supporting social enterprises to start
up and scale up
the project will fund support for social
enterprises across baber and mid suffolk
this project will harness the enthusiasm
to empower communities and set up
socially minded businesses that address
local issues and areas of need by
developing hyper
local micro enterprises to re-engage
local people in the workforce
bringing with them business skills that
benefit our economy
and community
to re create inclusive economic growth
such as community pops and shops
and that's the end of the presentation
from the community's chair
and i would like to
propose that the cabinet accept
recommendations three one three two and
three three which is in this report
thank you for that is there a second
birth
council osborne thank you
i'm gonna move on to um
to questions i'll take questions from
other members present first
um and then
come on to cabinet questions and debate
other councillors present have you got a
question on this
at all
no
okay
questions from cabinet members
no
yes councillor busby uh 6.2
in the report
which lists the six broad project themes
although
my report have only got five
uh john did mention the sixth but i
didn't
catch him the first one he mentioned i
think
could somebody tell me what that was
we can probably just council award he's
here yes please counselor yes yep um the
the first one right only five are listed
uh in the reporter for community
engagement and development
um okay thanks just as a as a thought of
a
theme that i shall be introducing
throughout this cabinet
do these six
project themes help towards achieving
the economic objectives one two and
three
you're referring to the previous
uh item on the agenda
yes
look i'll tell you what concerns me is
that if you if you actually go on into
the report to see the
if you read the uk government
questionnaire
it refers to us page four as having
average pay
which is below average
and qualifications
which are below average
and to me the three objectives that we
had in economy were one of the one of
the reasons for having those objectives
was to raise this average pay
and to raise the average qualifications
and again i don't necessarily see
these six projects trying to achieve
either either of those
okay can i just say that i'm just
starting to get a tiny bit concerned
that we're we're starting to engage john
ward in the debate which of course he
can't do
so it is strictly
yeah it is strictly um a question and an
answer
and i think he's gone as far as he could
in answering your original question
so i don't know fiona can you help with
a few more details
yes i can and so we uh given the short
time scales that we've been given to
pull this investment plan together
we absolutely didn't start with a blank
sheet of paper we took existing
priorities from our existing plans and
that includes from the economic recovery
plan but also included from the
communities and wellbeing plans
delivery plans so we have cherry-picked
projects from those plans so there is a
very direct link and what we've got in
the cabinet report here is is the sort
of high level
areas and because
we've been short of time and we're
continuing the consultation
we haven't yet uh completely pinned down
all of the direct interventions that
will go into the into the plan because
we're waiting for the results of the
consultation uh so as and when we get to
that i think you'll see more clearly a
very direct link back to our delivery
plans
okay thank you
councillor busby i sent another question
you said wrong okay
cabinet members any other questions
councilman mclaren
um i'd like to ask fiona a question
actually thank you
um
given the events of
the last few days
and the honourable member for
lovely knot was sacked
does this put at jeopardy
uh this these proposals that we've
worked very hard at
uh does it put that in jeopardy when we
submit them thank you
okay i think your question is national
events do they impact on this i'm
guessing the answer is no because the
funding is committed
i think my answer is i don't know um we
have a deadline of the 1st of august um
leveling up fund bid which is our other
major bid that
should have gone in
the portal the application portal hasn't
opened yet so i think there will be
delays but i might be wrong but i don't
think it would fundamentally change the
funding we get i just think it might
bring delays in
okay thanks
cabinet members any other comments
no
it's been proposed and seconded
um we are
using modern.gov for voting
so if there are no other questions or
debate
can you please vote yes yeah the vote is
on progress
chair i'm afraid to report somewhat
embarrassingly that my computer has
completely died on me
literally blank black screen of a lot
i'm trying to contact i.t because it's
friday so can we take your vote yes
i found a few locations
uh thank you chair that is five votes
for that's unanimous
move on to item
nine
which is bca 2214
the hamilton road quarter
regeneration scheme in sudbury
and again
using the wonders of technology i'm
hoping this is going to be introduced by
council john ward
yes i'm here ready to go
yes please thank you chairman
thank you i'd like to introduce paper
bca2214
which seeks cabinet approval to fund
progressing further work on the draft
hamilton road master plan following the
recent public exhibition in sudbury
this is a mixed-use regeneration of this
key gateway site featuring retail
leisure and other commercial uses as
well as as well as a residential
component
the master plan concept presented at the
exhibition is included in appendix a
in september 2018 cabinet endorsed the
current approach for for regenerating
this site and also development
prospectus to enable marketing of the
site nationally to gain development
interest and investment
however there are significant deterrents
to this as highlighted in paragraph 4.4
therefore we have been undertaking a
variety of intervention works to support
de-risking the site in order to increase
the likelihood of unlocking the delivery
of the site and these are listed in
paragraph 4.5
following the rejection of the round one
leveling up fund bid an updated round
two package submission has been prepared
for a capital grant application to cover
two aligned projects
our hamilton road call to regeneration
and suffolk county council highways
authorities bus infrastructure junction
and active travel improvements
a summary of the bid is included in
appendix b
we have already invested significantly
in the assembly of the site along with
related due diligence site
investigations and early design concept
work
architect and cost consultant works have
amounted to 106 000 pounds but this does
include bellevue site master plan work
elements as well
and it is much less than the numbers
claimed on social media
but this work has been essential to
submit a viable leveling up fund bid and
to support securing any potential future
funding investment or partnering
opportunities
i have mentioned all this because it is
important for everyone to understand the
complexity of regenerating a site such
as this
if it were easy would have been done by
now however it is essential that we
persevere and put in the effort an
upfront investment sudbury needs
and it will all be worthwhile eventually
we now need to move to the next phase
and continue to de-risk the site for
investment and seek to secure a
development partner to this end we
need
to improve
from the strategic priorities reserve
with all capital elements funded from
the 6.3 million pound capital
regeneration fund approved in the budget
a full business case including skiing
cost estimates and development viability
appraisals will be reported to cabinet
later this year
we should also know the outcome of the
leveling up fund bid sometime in the
autumn although as fiona has already
mentioned recent events could change
this there is also concern that the bid
portal which was scheduled to be
available at the end of may is still not
open
the interest shown in the public
consultation was great with many
visitors both residents and businesses
over the weekend it was held
and the feedback was overwhelmingly
positive
given this level of initial community
support
i would like to ask someone to propose
the recommendations exception three of
this report thank you chairman
thank you yeah that's um
3.1 to 3.3
and 3.5 and 3.6 there is no 3.4 just to
be clear
is there a proposal
councillor osborne thank you
under secondary council mclaren
okay
thank you um i'm going to take questions
um
from other councillors present first
do any of you have a question
councillor halt
thank you i've got four if i may
um with reference to 3.2 in the report
including its preference to explore
partnership with baby growth i do have
grave concerns about this
baby growth has no pedigree in
delivering this type of scheme and it's
questionable whether they have the skill
set to do so
so i would ask cabinet to be very
cautious about taking that approach i
appreciate it says explore but i think
for this
site with a site of this magnitude we
really do need the most expert
professional
teams involved as we can and i would
like to raise that point so please bear
that in mind if you would um
another point did you want to deal with
that as one question and then you can do
chair yeah i'll take further questions
yep
um i'm not quite sure who's best place
to answer this but i'm kind of looking
towards fiona again
um so i think council hall uh pointed
out um what we have in the report which
is we will investigate opportunities
with baby growth i don't think that's
compelling us to necessarily treat with
that and obviously both growth need to
assess the opportunity themselves so
okay thanks and we are talking about a
residential phase aren't we effectively
councillor busby did you want to help
with an answer to that as well
well no except well yes i do um
we work labour growth is a partnership
between weber and north who have do have
the skills and qualifications and
experience to deal with these kinds of
projects they've been doing in the past
we will not necessarily be
laying the bricks ourselves but we'll be
using the right kind of developer to do
these kind of things so
i think
i have confidence in vapor growth to do
that
thanks councillor holt
yeah next thing was really to do with if
this computer will work 4.5
um
the essential elements of this scheme
must be made clear
to the public uh by this i mean
the bus station going being removed the
new roundabout near waitrose and station
road and the on-street bus stops
this scheme cannot be allowed to be
derailed at a later stage the public and
businesses in suffering need to
understand the elements the key elements
that cannot be changed for this project
to be brought forward the regeneration
project and i think it's essential that
we get that message across the people
and if there is any debate to be had on
those sensitive areas it's held very
early on because what we don't want is
what we've had in the past is months and
months go on years go on and then all of
a sudden these sort of things come up so
i think it's essential
that we get those key elements out there
they can't be changed um they're
fundamental to delivery of this project
okay so that question is partly i think
about the knock-on effects of things
like the the
movement of the bus station correct
yeah so they're not directly related to
this scheme proposal but they're things
that will happen as a result you cannot
go ahead without the removal of the bus
station okay so what exactly is the
question you you want the question
reassurance question there's more
statement i want to ensure that we
you as a cabinet officers fully engaged
with with the public to make them aware
of the very key elements
of this regeneration program
that are fundamental to it going ahead
what we've had in the past is debate
going on and on and on especially the
bus station which has scuppered schemes
in the past and i think if we're honest
and upfront with people about the
fundamentals of this that can't be
changed i think we'll have a buy-in much
better than we did previously i'm sure
you're absolutely right and very good
points but i'm not sure there's a
question in there so well the question
is can we please ensure that we have
that commitment and involvement
yeah okay
i've got john ward who's nodding on the
screen i don't i was hoping that i might
wait until the answer to the end of the
questions and then invite you to answer
sort of
as as you feel fit is that okay
yeah yeah okay so yes you've got another
question counselor
yeah do the suffolk county council
improvements included
do they include those that are part of
the children was development and the
associated s106 funding so the key
elements again in the regeneration
program that county are involved with
and is key in some ways to delivering it
are some of those part of the children
woods
road improvements there was a numerous
amount of road improvements junction
improvements
linked to chilton woods are these going
to be associated with this regeneration
project and all that s 106 funding that
was tied up with the sale of children
would be put into this regeneration
scheme
my initial reaction is i didn't think
the chilton woods highway improvement
monies
were applicable here but i'm looking
again to fiona for some help
so
so the the
the junction scheme to
release the bus station to be an
on-street facility are not directly
linked to children's woods
we are having conversations with county
council at the moment with regard to any
other funding that could be available to
help facilitate the junction
improvements and so i can't really
categorically say yes or no but i don't
recall there was anything in section 106
children would necessarily link to the
the new job on the street provision okay
thank you
just coming back on that i mean
i'm not sure if we have a clear
understanding of what junction
improvements were part of chiltonwood
but as in the past in sudbury we've had
piecemeal projects come forward i think
it'd be
a much better position if we fully
understood what those junction
improvements were so that we have a
coordinated approach to the traffic
schemes the bus stops
so that we aren't um
overlapping in any way with what
children want to bring forward and what
we hope to bring forward with um the
regeneration project yeah i think that
point's been taken
and have you got one more question
okay is the cabinet committed to
delivering this scheme regardless of the
success of the level or not fund bid
as with the previous cabinet i sat on
it's important that we have the fourth
political parties
firm of commitment and agreement along
with the independent members
so that we have
to bear in mind that
from may 2023 we'll have a new
administration
um
and a lot of things could change with
the members sitting here today so i
think if we can get that political
buy-in from the foreign political groups
that should carry forward this the
momentum of this regeneration scheme
into the next council so i'd like to see
that we can get the buy-in from all
those political groups
yeah it's not really a question but a
good point well made and i agree with
you
okay council award have you saved up
some answers to some of those questions
i have
two answers i think um
firstly about the the key elements um of
the bus station removal and um
the associated junction improvements um
we will continue to keep them council
holds right we do need to make sure that
the public is is fully aware um of of
those requirements and
they were all highlighted very clearly
in the public exhibition the other week
and we will continue to put the that
message across so um uh that there's
there's no
need to have no fear that uh that that
will not be uh highlighted continually
over the forthcoming months and secondly
um with regard to commitment uh
regardless of the success or not of the
leveling up fund bid
absolutely yes um i think i speak on
behalf of everyone we we are committed
to that success um
and we will also look at um
obviously things that to do with the
phasing of the scheme viability um uh in
terms of what other potential funding
sources there are um as an alternative
to that and again we will be working
with suffolk county council on on their
aspects of of the work the junction work
because they are committed to supporting
the bus station move um so there's
there's there's total commitment by both
baba and suffolk county council for this
thank you council award
um well
is this another question that's a
statement really uh certainly i
mentioned about the four political
parties the conservative groups
certainly will be supporting this
regeneration scheme
it is questions only
i do find that strange when we're
invited to speak and i'd like to think
we are able to be well you you can't
take part in the debate and you can't
make statements but thank you for your
participation you've said a lot of a lot
of good sensible things councilor owen
yeah
yeah thank you for that um just to ask
is everyone on board
on this at the moment because obviously
you've had problems before with
the actually buying up the land and
things like that is have you talked to
everyone now so is everyone on board
um we've certainly talked to everyone um
i can't say at this point in the
project that we've signed up everybody
in terms of the land ownerships there
were 50 different title registrations
across the whole site which we've been
working through we have certainly made
contact and are having a dialogue with
everyone
another question
it's just coming back on that really
what happens um
are you going to go compulsory if you
can't get them on board or
because this is a big project isn't it
so
it is a big project um
as you know cpo is expensive and
time-consuming so it might be something
that the cabinet might wish to
answer at some point in time for now i
think we've made good progress in terms
of those negotiations and obviously
councils do have powers to use cpo
ultimately if they wish to
i think there's a cross council
commitment to getting this done
um i've been a councillor for 31 years
and over those 31 years there has
throughout those 31 years there has been
talk about what to do with this area of
sudbury and to be honest nothing's been
delivered at all really so it's about
time we got something done
okay that's it for your questions
councilman yep councillor dawson
um yes i have two questions um one is uh
what concerns me slightly about this is
i can't see what is your timeline on
this
because we don't really want another
cork's lane
and my second question is i was slightly
concerned as i understand uh one of the
retailers is just going to hang out to
use their shop as a ransom strip
and then you mentioned you've been in
discussion with 50 people so
all these people if they know we want
this they're just going to be charging
extortion amounts of money
so have you put
have you sort of worked that into the
equation
with all of this and i'm not quite sure
without the timeline and not knowing
what the costs are
whether this is ever really going to go
forward
sorry your question is
what is the
timeline very clearly the timeline is it
are you expecting this in five years 10
years i don't know what the timeline is
for and secondly
if there are 50 people to be spoken to
if one of those which i believe is the
case is holding get a hold their shop is
a ransom strip
what is the budget for this because
you're going to get one person who's
going to say well i'm not going to sell
to stop the whole thing
so it could just go on indefinitely
i think we've already had the answer
sorry well i think we've already had the
answer to your second question and that
is that we do have compulsory purchase
powers um the answer to your first
question sorry sorry i'm sorry sorry
sorry i'll come back to you the answer
to your first question i think is a
timeline for delivery and i think that's
a bit harder to pinpoint isn't it i'll
ask the owner to help
um so we've certainly for the purposes
of the
loft bid had to
identify
some time some time skills um
clearly the next phase of work will
start to shape those um and there are
you know we've also identified a large
risk register that goes alongside that
so there are always going to be things
that move i'm just going to hand over to
lee because lee has got some time skills
that we're putting into this i think
thank you i think it's a great project
i'm sorry
i can't have with questions i can't have
this sort of interaction going on
sorry exactly you interrupted
i told you that i would come back to you
after we've had an attempt to answer
your question just to make sure that
your question has been answered so can
you please let the answers count i'd
appreciate it
i will come back to you please thank you
please don't interrupt thank you
um lee carvalho
thank you um yeah for the leveling up
fun bid we've had to project a timeline
um
we've also got a compulsory purchase
order
um assessment on cost from cart jonas
would have done open market values and
we have modeled some of that into the
ask for the leveling up fund bid as well
just so that the cat the government are
potentially going to be helping with
those costs
in terms of the delivery of phase one
for levelling up fund bid purposes and
obviously given there are risks
ahead of that
we've projected march 2025
completion and for phase two november of
2025 and that does accord with the
leveling up fund time frame
so could i come back on that
um
are you asking a new question or asking
for a clarification on the previous
question
i'd like to ask so
i'm what i'm really getting at
is is phase is this the end what is the
final date for completion of this
project
just just you know
okay i don't think we know that yet but
i mean could you fiona could you give us
some sort of indication of the time
scale we're talking
of
if if it progresses through this council
and if if the next council continue to
progress it
what is the likely delivery time
so as lee said for the purposes of
the time scales around the loft bid
because we've had to do extensive work
for that bid and we have
projected
that if none of the risks materialize
and
if we continue on a positive trajectory
in terms of acquisitions etc that we
could have practical completion of phase
two of the schemes that's the second
phase by 20 and end of 2025.
i will caveat that though by saying
big town centre projects like this are
fraught with challenges and that's our
best estimate as we sit here today
um
you mentioned the 50 different titles
which by the way are titles they're not
necessarily owners or landowners um but
every step of the way we will have to
stop and look at the risk so that time
scale could change but that's our best
estimate at the moment
okay so the answer to your question is
could be as soon as
2025. with the caveat and then my other
question is you could just again um
so there is not a budget uh what you're
saying is we will compulsory purchase
these shops where people might try to
hold us ransom definitely or and that
applies to all retailers
i'm not sure if that's another question
you've already been told that we do have
the powers of compulsory purchase if
they're necessary
so thank you what what is different
about this question
okay
sorry
i've just asked you the question well
you don't ask fiona questions you come
through me so what is the question
do you want me to repeat it again please
right
we've we've just assessed that it might
be compulsory purchase and i have asked
is this absolutely for all people all
retailers
on that side all would be compel if
there's any i mean hopefully there won't
be any issues with any of them but if
there are inter
can i just seek confirmation that you
will be compulsory purchasing
all those properties which is i think
what you said i'm not quite sure it's
what i'm asking
no that's not the intention at all is it
um
i think the question has been answered
but i'll give you a little bit of
latitude if you don't think it has i'm
going to ask fiona if she can just
expand on her answer a little bit to
satisfy you could you ever write
something you can't keep coming back
emily could i have a right of all to
hear i think i think this is out of line
well
i'm sorry but you're speaking at my
discretion i would like to ask a polite
question counselor dawson if i choose
that you can't speak at all then you
can't speak at all i'm trying to get an
answer to your question okay if you just
let that happen please
fiona
yeah i can answer very quickly thank you
all of our cost estimates include
provision if we have to take a cpo
so they will have an additional amount
in them
thank you okay
those councillors here who are not
members of cabinet if you finished your
questions
it looks like you have
members of cabinet
councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman um yeah just in in
answer to councillors holt's concern on
the chilton development two years ago um
suffolk county council produced a really
comprehensive document on all the
mitigation that they were putting into
place in regards to the infrastructure
and i've got access to that so i can
always forward it to council hall if
you'd like to see it
on the hamilton road
of course absolutely 100 in fact 200 do
i support
this project it's it will be the making
of sudbury it would be fantastic and
it i
i can't
emphasize enough how much i support it
and that's one of the reasons i seconded
it today the site has proved to be
really challenging
and that's why it gets delays on it and
that's only to be expected excuse me
with a project of this size now my
question is
we've got the leveling up fund and
hopefully fingers crossed toes across
everything else that that will be
successful
however and i have mentioned this before
have we got a plan b in place in the
event of us being unsuccessful with the
leveling up bid
because if we don't have a plan b in
place
we it will then put us back months and
months even possibly
eight years so do we have a plan b in
place now for the a in the event that
the 11 and up fund is unsuccessful
i'm guessing that's a question for fiona
for you again i'm sorry
that's okay um so we don't really have
one plan b there are a number of options
that the cabinet could look at in the
event that leveling up is unsuccessful
and i'll just go through those very
quickly one is that
we could change the scheme uh make it
smaller take stuff out of it um the
other one is that it just becomes more
expensive
for whoever ends up funding it um and
the final one is that we bring in other
external funding and we're looking at
that with suffolk county council at the
moment
okay
any other questions
council mclaren thank you chair i think
this is for council award actually if
he's still on the line
yeah i was going to come back to council
award before we move into debate because
of course he can't take part in the
debate so i was going to come back to
council award before we moved to debate
just to see if there are any answers to
any of the questions
in the risk management section of this
paper
there is
a i'm trying to see how many one two
three four five six the sixth one down
relates to the failure to provide strong
local leadership within sudbury vision
program
that stifles the wider town investment
opportunities i would like that
explained to me i
wasn't sure who it was actually
referring to chair
who did you think that was a question
for
well i i was going to address council
award actually i thought he might love
that okay
i'm happy with fiona
okay if we can get council award back if
he's willing to answer that question or
if there are any other questions that he
wanted to add an answer to
council award
uh yeah there's
other questions i think they've all been
answered fairly clearly now um
and and i have also myself earlier
provided some some answers so um uh the
the commitment is there um
should the leveling up fund uh not be
successful we will be seeking
alternative funding which we've got
commitment from suffolk county council
as i mentioned earlier
so um all aspects of this we definitely
will uh pursue with as much haste as
possible
um but um
as i've
mentioned before
under the complexity
however um to
the the leadership we have had in the
past a partnership board um with various
parties in in sudbury uh to push forward
the vision that we have for the town
this is the vision for prosperity
um that has has fallen into obeying but
we are committed to
restarting something similar that will
involve not just baba but the town
council and various business partners in
the town to make sure that there is that
uh cohesive
and comprehensive local leadership
to deliver this plus a number of other
major schemes in sudbury so
that's really what this this particular
risk is is alluding to um and the fact
that um
we we do need to ensure that we have
that um
uh that that kind of a body with that
sort of membership so that there is the
confidence that um that the vision will
will be progressed over the years to
come
thank you thank you chair
thank you
okay any other questions
moving to debate
cabinet members
if you have anything further to add by
way of debate council busby
yeah uh thanks cheer
i'm worried about this
uh
i'm concerned about the design the
layout
if we look at appendix a
the page three of its
there's a block of well the residential
block
is
four five three four five stories high
surrounding a green area i'm not
convinced there's going to be much sun
get into that green area
i also like to know how the security
will be provided for that area
and the same kind of applies for the
green area behind the hotel stroke
cinema
it's
almost blocked off
from the street
i just think
there's a better way of laying that out
so that the green space
is more visible
and also
the residential block doesn't become
a slum area i think it's just i'm not
convinced that it's
going to be an attractive feature it's
going to be too high so i'd like what
i'd like to see is a scale
model
of that area so that we can get an idea
on perception
uh of the
of the space itself
yeah firstly can i just be clear about
which block you're talking about you're
talking about the one kind of in the
middle of the development are you that
four-story block that sort of creates a
courtyard effect
it yeah it does it uh it's
high as well
it's at least four story isn't it by
looking by the number of windows
yeah the whole thing is high i think
even the smallest ones are at least
three-story high
okay i think part of it's this part of
what you're saying is probably a
question for either leo fiona
and it's about
the
sketch that's been done and how that
ties in with our recommendation
um which has been proposed and seconded
which is that we endorse in principle
the draft master plan scheme
um absolutely i appreciate that this is
a marginal scheme and we've got to try
and
not say cram but get as much residential
units in there as possible to make the
scheme at all viable
but there is a balance between
viability and design and i'm not
convinced that this is
tipped in the right direction at the
moment well i thought part of your
question was if if we approve this today
are we committing ourselves to that i
think was
is that part of yours that's your
interpretation of mine that's not what
you're asking at all
maybe in a minute
right so to hear the answer to the to
the to my question no it's not a
question
which are that you don't think that that
will be a particular concern about the
designs i'd like to have some
clarification
from lee that my concerns are ill-found
okay we'll we'll see if we can do that
is that leo or fiona perhaps fiona
lee might have to uh come in but um
these are concept schemes they are they
have formed the basis of the um
financial work that we've done um but
they are concept schemes and i have
absolutely no doubt that the final
scheme will be different but it's more
around the concept of the components on
the site so for example the hotel
building which is the one that is
nearest to the church shows a 60 bed
hotel you know we're talking to someone
protesting 160 beds we're talking some
operative zoo 140 beds
that's not tied down yet but the
principle of the two of the two phases
are residential being on one part of the
site the largely commercial use of thing
and the other part of the site
the links through uh from opposite voice
the sort of pedestrian linked through
the areas of public realm and they're
the sort of core principles of the
master plan that we are hoping cabinet
will approve
there will undoubtedly be some tweaking
and you know i'm pretty sure by the time
we get to a planning application we've
been made to do
daylight studies you know where the
shadowing is all of that work still has
to come we're just not at that stage so
i would urge cabinet to just view it as
a
high level master plan at this stage
which has enabled us to go to the next
stage
okay shall we just
council busby do you want to explore
what you said might be your next
question because i think that would be
useful as well so if we commit ourselves
today to 3.1
what does that mean i mean i'm guessing
that you wrote this that cabinet endorse
in principle the draft master plan
scheme layout as attached
um so
by saying in principle we mean
sort of the components and broadly where
they are on the site
rather than necessarily um exactly that
configuration of housing for example
i would caveat that i think you said it
yourself counselor buzzfeed and in order
to make this scheme viable there does
need to be a quantum of development on
it so i think it's really unlikely we'll
end up seeing two-story housing on the
site because that will not achieve the
viability
and you know that is the reason this
scheme has not come forward in the past
with a private sector developer because
they cannot make it viable so that is
why we the council are looking at how we
can give it some leadership and so i'm
not going to
i'm not going to say that you know we'll
end up with 20 houses on this site and
if we do and that's a choice that
cabinet make later down the line um it
will be a scheme that you'll have to
accept is not viable
yeah
okay
councillor busby
yeah i'm happy to go forward uh under
the premise that there will be further
discussion then
we'll need to consider it in phases
the viability of each phase may may
differ i mean i think the residential
phase
would be viable probably however many
units we went for i guess what we're
looking for is some funds from
phase one to help fund phases two three
whatever
uh
but if four functioning phases two and
three change then maybe we don't need
quite so much funding from phase one
so
given that this is the early stage of
this project
and that there will be potential changes
i'm happy to support it okay and just a
little bit more on that i'm guessing
that we will be having further
engagement with the man from klh who has
come up with this concept
um who when he briefed us i have to say
i thought was excellent
um and
at that point i'm sure that um
councillor buzz b will
both be able to say what he's just said
he'll also be able to listen to the
reasoning um and
also be reassured that the scheme might
change a bit
yeah because
they're reporting back to baby growth so
yeah i think that i hope we're all
wholly supportive of the principle of
the regeneration scheme councilman cruel
yeah i'm just looking through um the
concept layout because it is a concept
um but we are dealing with general
principles and i'm looking at the
i'm looking at the um
proposals you know the actual
recommendations and the fact of the
point of all of this is that these are
all necessary steps this is what we do
have to do to make progress it's a
step-by-step process this is the next
step if we've already accepted the idea
that this has been presented to the
public
generally very positive at that approach
and a very positive response from the
people who went to the exhibition i was
impressed myself uh listened and a few a
little bit of background murmur of
people were like that like that um i
don't have the fears concerning that
that block of housing based on the
illustration
shown simply because i can only see
three stories there but it could be four
it could be three it could be two i
don't know i'm not an architect the
point is we need to do this this is how
we go forward we'll agree we want to go
forward these are the things we need to
do so i'll be voting for it
okay thank you
government members i just wanted to jim
fiona did you manage to get in touch
with the regal
yes but they haven't come back with any
answers yet but i can supply that
afterwards
that was based on i just want to know
the viability of a small cinema
like what the viability of this small
cinema would be in sudbury so i asked
fiona to look at
how the regal's fair since we've
refurbished it
okay
any other comments if not i'm going to
take it to the vote um i want to just
remind you that the
recommendations that you're voting on
are 3.1 to 3.3 and 3.5 and 3.6 so those
are five recommendations there not six
okay and we've spoken about the first
one which is the in principle approval
um
3.2 is the preference for a two-phased
approach
and the um the exploration of the
partnership with baby growth for phase
one
um there's 3.3
up to a maximum of 500 000 pounds from
the strategic priorities reserve
um
three point five three point five as i
said miss out three point four
um that's for delegated authority
and three point six is the cabinet note
the summary information contained within
appendix b
relating to the council's resubmission
of proposals to uk government for
levelling up funding at round two stage
are you clear about that
yes
so if we can then um move to
the vote i'll ask you please to conduct
the electronic vote yes thank you the
vote's now in progress
council mccrory take your vote please
in favor thank you
thank you chair that is uh five votes
for that's unanimous
okay thank you for that
move on to item 10
which is bca
2215
the hadley a 1071 roadside commercial
workspace development
and i'm hoping that
with successful technology again this
can be introduced by councillor john
ward
yep uh technology is always always
successful at paper
right
i would like to introduce paper
bca2215 which provides cabinet with a
progress update on the hadley a1071
roadside commercial workspace
development since the scheme was
supported at our meeting on the 8th of
june last year when we authorized the
detailed development of a viable scheme
and business case just to remind
everyone this scheme will be developed
on
one and a half acres of land acquired by
baber from persimmon homes under a
section 106 agreement
the proposal for the site approved last
year comprises a two-story office
building up to 10 light industrial units
and a retail convenience store
section 4 of the report provides
evidence for the need for startup and
incubates incubator space and also
further information confirming our
desire and ability to fill the gap in
private sector provision of this type of
site
it also highlights how we can be
proactive in demonstrating that new
housing can deliver local jobs a good
message for the community in hadley and
others in the district our preference
last year was for letting all
candidates to generate a long longer
term revenue stream for the council
we now have a prospective key anchor
tenant for the office building but we
didn't get any interest for the
convenience retail portion from
convenience store operators on a
leasehold basis
however we did get conditional and
non-conditional offers to purchase the
freehold of that area of the site
use of 100 of the sale receipts to help
deliver the whole scheme would improve
the viability assessment of the project
reduce our borrowing costs and still
allow us to retain the benefit of longer
term letting income on their units on
the remainder of the site
this is all covered in the outline
business case presented in confidential
appendix d
the conditional offers worth more than
the unconditional one
so it is that officer offer that forms
the basis of recommendation 3.2
now this really does represent the best
option for the development of this site
mitigating risk and maximizing income
for the council and i would like to ask
someone to propose the recommendations
at section 3 of this report
please note that all the appendices
contain confidential information
relating to the proposed land sale
therefore we will have to go to
confidential session to ask questions or
discuss any of the matters presented in
them
so i urge members to think before
straying into this territory thank you
chairman
thank you council award
so first of all can i have a proposal
councillor mccraw
secondary
council mclaren thank you very much
okay so as council award has said um we
have got
some documents labelled restricted
so i'd ask you to
respect the confidential nature of those
which contain commercially sensitive
information
so i'm going to
go to
councillors that are here that are not
members of cabinet first
for any questions
please respect the fact that these are
questions in open session
if you need to ask a question in closed
session then we can deal with that later
on
so council is present any questions
councillor holt
yeah um
i would like to confirm the capital the
conservative group support this scheme
is why i personally been heavily
involved in bringing forward and i'm
pleased to see it in front of cabinet
today
which hopefully you will approve i'm
just keen to find out what the timeline
is so the question again similar to
councillor dawson's earlier is what
rough timeline have we got for delivery
of this project should you approve it
today
okay
good question and i think i'm probably
going to look towards fiona again for an
answer
so this particular decision relates to
the disposal largely disposal of uh part
of the site and we can move quite
quickly on that so argent envisaged
certainly within um
the next uh three to four months that we
could formalize legal terms on on that
particular one and that then
in addition uh the work that's already
commenced on the wider site will
continue um and um it's difficult for me
to give a time skill on that because we
are still negotiating with the potential
anchor tenant and
they're not moving quite as quickly as i
would like
so um it's difficult for me to give an
actual time scale on that one
thank you that's it thank you okay thank
you
any anybody else with the question
council dawson
um yes finally asked my question um it's
just concerning what i'd like is a
recommendation from the cabinet
at this stage um before it sort of goes
to planning
is that this will be obscured from the
road because one of the things that
residents are really concerned about
what we don't want is coming along and
baby plonking in uh this development
which can be seen from the road
so can we make a caveat that it's
acceptable because i think it's a great
scheme but with proper landscaping to
obscure it from the road
very simple recommendation that can be
easily included i'm sure
um that's all i'd like to ask
well yeah i'm not sure about that as a
question i think what you're asking is
could
cabinet attach some sort of a caveat
regarding visibility from the road yeah
that is what i'm asking i'm not sure if
we could it's a planning issue
but could you make a recommendation that
you would like to see that which you can
do
i don't i don't think we could do that
okay um sorry
i don't believe that's legal i don't
think we can as a cabinet make a
recommendation for anything affecting
the planning process
but i think i think it's a it's an
interesting point that's been made um by
council dawson um and i'm sure that um
with regard to the the subsequent
planning application that may well
follow um that's a point that she can
she can make
we won't be the applicant of course
council dawson does that answer your
question
okay
thanks any other questions from
non-cabinet members
no cabinet
questions
council busby
yeah i see in the
contract the terms which we won't talk
about in detail but there's
what happens if the purchaser decides to
change the use of the site
i know it's specified in
here for a particular use but
is there anything to prevent the
purchaser saying well i can't make that
work i need to come up with something
else and
come on yeah i think there's an answer
to that isn't it because i think that
question's been asked before
fiona
um yeah without straying into the
confidential terms there is a term
in the confidential terms uh which
relates to
them having to secure planning consent
for a particular use
so the contract is conditional on that
okay but if again they could gain
planning consent for that particular use
but then decide that they don't want to
go forward with it and come forward with
another planning application
which would
require a new consent
yeah
yes at the moment the way the tens of
terms were did yes you're correct they
could get planning consent uh purchase
the site and then do something else
i would add though this particular site
there are fairly limited options and we
will be putting in something that says
they can't build residential on the site
because we have a covenant ourselves
around residential so we'd be passing
that on as part of the title and but
other than that i think they'll be
fairly limited with the kind of uses
they can get on the site anyway
okay i'm guessing that the reason you're
asking that question is because it's
possible that they can get planning
consent for the use that they've
described and then sit on it
yeah they could sit on it
the two alternatives are
if having gained planning consent they
find that it's
not viable they can't actually find
somebody to run it it just becomes a
vacant site
or
having decided that they then come
forward with an alternative use which
doesn't fit in with the rest of the
cycle
okay but it would require planning
commission
so it would come to you or your
successes for approval
fiona
we can put as many restrictions on the
sale of the land as we want the more
restrictions we put in the less value so
we've tried to maintain it as open as
possible
whilst using a conditional contract to
attempt to steer them in the direction
that we want
and the question for you councillor
busby if it was an appropriate use
would that necessarily worry us
we didn't come up with the use it was
somebody who was proposing no if it's an
appropriate use yeah fine it's a
28-story block of flats then maybe not
quite so okay
thanks
cabinet members
any other questions anything by way of
debate
no
okay
in that case i don't think we need to go
um
into closed session
so i think we can actually take the um
take the vote on the recommendations
which are at
paragraph three
that's 3.1 3.2 3.3 and 3.4
you all clear
yes
okay
so can we take the electronic vote
please thank you chair the vote is now
in process progress sorry
sorry councilman
in favor
okay
thank you chair that is five votes for
that is unanimous
okay
so that has actually concluded um all of
our business the closed session was
uncalled for
unnecessary
um
so um
just remains for me to say thank you
very much our next scheduled meeting is
monday the 5th of september
at 2 o'clock thank you very much
you